ニューラルネットワークは機械学習アルゴリズムの中でも強力なクラスです
そして多くの種類があります
入門的な動画でニューラルネットワークを適切に扱うことは
難しいです
ここではいくつかの重要な構成要素のみを取り上げます
ニューラルネットワークの構成要素と全体的なワークフローを
理解することで、量子コンピューティングがどのように貢献できるかを見ていきます
ニューラルネットワークはニューロンが接続されたグラフです
ニューロンとは基本的に数値を保持するものです
その数値は「活性化」と呼ばれることが多く、
そのニューロンがどれだけオンかオフかを表します
ニューロンはいくつかの層に分かれています
最初の層は入力層です
最後の層は出力層です
その間には処理に使われる層があり、
隠れ層と呼ばれます。入力層の
活性化は、分析対象のデータから直接読み込まれます
例えば画像のピクセルの濃淡などです
次の隠れ層の活性化は
入力層のニューロンによって決まります
そしてすべてのニューロンを接続する線で表される重みによっても決まります
入力層のすべてのニューロンから
次の層のすべてのニューロンへ。つまり隠れ層のニューロンの活性化は
隠れ層のニューロンの活性化は
すべての入力活性化の
重み付き和によって決まります
バイアス（シフト）を
加えることもできます。隠れ層のニューロンを活性化させたいのは
重み付き和が単に正の場合だけでなく
大きな閾値を超えた場合のみということもあります
その後、活性化を得るために複雑な関数を適用することがよくあります
0から1の間の値にするために、双曲線正接関数などを使います
あるいは別の関数として
正規化線形ユニット（ReLU）を使うこともあります。今は
これらについてあまり気にする必要はありません。ここで
これらの関数について重要なのは
非線形であるということです
これにより、ネットワーク全体として線形と
非線形の両方の要素を持つことになります
今度は同じ活性化の重み付き和を使います
今度は
最初の隠れ層の活性化と新しい重みから始めて
次の隠れ層へと拡張していきます
これが最終層まで続き、最終層が出力となります
出力層にはカテゴリに対応するニューロンがあり
活性化の値がネットワークの
分類の確信度を示します
例えば画像分析の出力カテゴリが
犬、猫、ハムスターなどだとします
犬のニューロンの活性化が0.95であれば
その画像が犬である可能性が非常に高いことを示します
ニューラルネットワークはランダムな重みのセットから始めることがあります
ランダムな重みのセットから始めたり
バイアスや、妥当な初期設定が分かっている場合はそこから始めたりします
次に、ニューラルネットワークの
分類精度を確認して
改善していきます。コスト関数を使って
ニューラルネットワークが
正しい分類からどれだけ外れているかを表します。これは
画像の実際の値と予測値の差を取ることを含みます
例えば犬のニューロンの値が1で
他のすべての出力ニューロンが0という場合と
予測値を比較します
すべてのカテゴリにわたって合計を取ります
これにより、正しいカテゴリが最も高く活性化されているかどうかだけでなく
確認できるだけでなく
誤った活性化が減っているかどうかも追跡できます
訓練セット内のすべての例について合計を取り
コストを算出します。そして
各層の重みなどのパラメータを
全ニューロン間やすべてのバイアスで変化させます
古典的な最適化ルーティンを使って
コスト関数の局所的な最小値を探します
この複雑さを軽減する対策が何もなければ
想像してみてください、どれほど
膨大なパラメータ空間を設定したかを
例えば画像を分析するために設計されたニューラルネットワークを考えてみましょう
たった1000ピクセルの画像に対して、このニューラルネットワークは1000個の
入力ニューロンを持ち、隠れ層が1つだけで
猫か犬かという2値の出力を持つとします
これは最も単純なケースです
それでも1000×1000、
つまり100万個の重みが入力層と隠れ層の間に存在します
さらに隠れ層と出力層の間に
2000個の重みがあります
さらに1000個程度の
バイアスもあります。つまりこのシンプルなニューラルネットワークでも
100万個以上のパラメータに対応します。もっとも公平に言えば
現代のアルゴリズムは通常、簡略化を行っています
古典的なニューラルネットワークにおいて
この最小化を実現するために専門の分野が存在し
効率的に行えるようにもなっています
しかし依然として、これは非常に
高次元の問題です
ニューラルネットワークの訓練は
非常に時間がかかります
そしてコストも高いです。量子ニューラルネットワーク（QNN）は
まず入力データを読み込み
その後量子circuit を適用します
これが層間の重みに対応します
そして最後に測定の層があります
これについていくつかの重要なポイントがあります。データの
読み込みと重み付けは線形演算ですが
測定は非線形です
古典的なニューラルネットワークと同様に
線形と非線形の両方の要素を持っています
また重みのcircuit には
変分パラメータがあります
そのため、古典的な最小化処理が依然として必要です
もちろん、これは量子ニューラルネットワークの表面に触れたに過ぎませんが
量子ニューラルネットワークの応用について学び続けることを願っています
量子ニューラルネットワークや
その他の量子機械学習の応用について
IBM Quantumと共に学んでいきましょう